betrunken können sehr unangenehm sein und sehr
wütend werden der einzige Menschenschlag der
meines Wissens genauso wütend werden kann
sind Politiker wenn man es wagt sie wörtlich
zu zitieren [Musik] guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
und willkommen bei Streitgespräch wie immer laden
wir Sie ein der kontroversen Diskussion zweier
Politiker gegensätzlicher Anschauung beizuwohnen
zu meiner Rechten dr Kraus zu meiner Linken herr
Werner Kronen bitte Herr grün eröffnen sie das
Streitgespräch ich frage als erstes beim Chaos
hier vor Millionen von Zuschauern wie steht es
mit der vielen diskutierten nationalen Kultur
Stiftung ach wenn du dieser uralte Hut den sie
davor zaubern jawohl ein uralterhut der immer noch
nicht vom Tisch ist der nationalkulturstift und
diesem unausgegorenen Kind gehts ausgezeichnet
wir haben bereits 50 Millionen verschwendet
bald wenn es 100 sein davon hätten sie nie zu
träumen gewagt eine nationale Schande genau
wie ihr Vorschlag zur Sanierung der Bundesbahn
und wie steht's mit der Misswirtschaft in der
Subventionspolitik besser denn je ich wurde
gerne darauf antworten aber Sie können es
nicht oder und ich werde es tun wenn sie zur
stumpft Vorsorge hier ein Programm vorlegen
sie wissen Sie wohl das immer wenn wir das Land
verlassen Sturmflut geschützt haben anschließend
eine Dürre Katastrophe eintrat alles leere
Versprechung wie mit der Bildungsreform
die Sie zu verhindern halten und der
Kostendämpfung im krankenwesen hören
sie haben wieder einmal erlebt wie widersprüchlich
politische Argumente sein können und müssen
sie hörten das Streitgespräch zwischen Herrn Dr
Kraus von der Regierungskoalition und
Herrn Werner Gruhn von der Regierungs
stimmt doch was nicht hören
ja beide der gleichen Parteien
[Musik]